and if you know me and if you listen to
every episode of this podcast or other
podcasts you know I haven't had Taco
Bell since I was what 19 that's
20 three years I haven't had Taco Bell
in 23 years 23 years you might be like
well why don't you just say 25 why don't
you just say 20 and I would reply
because I know it's been 203 years and
then you'd be like why and then I say
because I remember when I vowed never to
eat Taco Bell ever again and then you
might say well how do you know exactly
when that was but then I would
specifically say I was 19 because that's
when I was at NYU standing outside of a
Taco Bell that I just ate and I thought
you know what that wasn't that good I'm
never going to eat this again and I'm
going to remember this moment for the
rest of my
life what a [__] lunatic dude but I
did it and I [__] stuck to it and I I
didn't realize that that was my OCD in
effect until a decade and a half later
[Music]
dude he's got
problems so we're watching the staircase
and they all get the idea and by they I
mean the
girls to order Taco Bell and I'm
specifying that it's girls
because you know
if there is a co-ed Gathering going on
and somebody orders gets the idea or the
hankering for Taco Bell it's it's it's a
woman who's drank a little bit you know
and the guys go sure and then they eat
more than the chicks obviously because
chicks you know they'll do like half a
[__] Cheesy Gordita and the dude's
like yeah dude I'll house
that so they say do you want Taco Bell
and I'm a little bit offended because
know me friends no I don't want Taco
Bell and they say you sure and now I'm
doubly mad because I've already answered
and you also should know but also no and
then they say okay and then they go to
order and they say are you sure you
don't want anything and I don't say
anything because number one know me
number two also I answered
it and number three you're being
disrespectful now trust I know my
opinion so I just stare and they go all
right so they get some cheesy gorditas
and some nachos and [__] and it shows up
finally and it's way too late you know
the Postmates driver is doing the thing
where he's like oh no that address
actually doesn't exist like they'll just
say [__] sorry I'm late there was a
dragon in the
way Postmates oh dude you know what
happened I don't care you might actually
there was a [__] crystalia rally I was
trying to get through I actually believe
that sir
um so anyway we get to the [__] they
get to the door they get to the door and
we get to the all the gorditas show up
and they're like and and they still you
want to bite and I'm like look you know
this about me I haven't had Taco Bell in
23 years and then my buddy says how do
you even know that and I go through what
I just told you I said you know because
I remember the moment and your boy was
19 and it's probably an OCD thing and
whatever and then Kristen
says okay will you please try this what
the [__] is it called berry blast do you
know what it's called it's like the new
drink at Taco Bell Baja Blast that's
what it's called Baja Blast is Baja a
[__] flavor like you know it's not
right does anyone ever [__] tries
something and they're like M tastes like
Baja the [__] out of here call it Berry
or whatever and I say no I'm not going
to I'm not going to I'm not going to
drink that I don't want to try a Baha
Blast and she says please I knew you're
going to say that but just try it for me
and now I'm put back on my heels why
because why the [__] do you care so much
what kind of Baja [__] goes in my
mouth and she was like it's so good and
I just want you to experience it and I
say this is not really like the kind of
experience that I want to have and she
says please like for me and I say why
for you it's for me and just because I
want to share this and you're growing
and you're growing as a person and you
you're trying new [__] and I say [__] I
just went on a
boat you think just
because I'm not landlocked anymore that
you can just throw a Baja Blast inside
my face no no no no no you're pushing
your
luck see this is why I should have never
got on that boat right before you know
it I'll move to Silver Lake have a
twisty mustache a monacle and a top hat
and people will be asking me if they
could pass
go I'm me
[__] so I'm like I don't want
this Baja Blast and she says please and
I say babe look I really I appreciate it
I don't want the Baja Blast and I say
why do you want me to have it if I don't
want it she say cuz you don't know you
know you don't want it and I said I
haven't had Taco Bell in 23 years and
she says but this isn't even really Taco
Bell and I said where'd you get
it and she goes and walks away and now
I'm the bad guy woohoo I don't consent
to this Taco Bell though he pressuring
me and then my buddy says you're a
[__] idiot man it's so good and then
I ask his girlfriend and I say is it
good and she goes like this literally
like
this and for the not audio for the
audio listeners it was a very
deep uh concerned look and a nod up and
down like I'd love to be on your side
but this Baja Blast is is is really
something to write home about so now I'm
like everyone's against me dude I lost
the [__] staircase HBO Max
traumatization of the [__]
documentary and now I [__] I lost we
watching documentary and now I'm going
to lose to this Baja blasting but my OCD
is strong but then I realized it is my
OCD and I said look baby it's my OCD and
she's like oh really if it is then I
won't bother it and now I feel like a
[__] so yes she's winning on all
accounts yes not only on the bad guy yes
I'm a [__]
yes he's a scared [__] which is
something that his ex called him and
that's when he realized that was the end
of his relationship yes dude yes you
don't call someone a scared [__] unless
you want the relationship to be over and
then I [__] took it and for a few
weeks I lived with it and then Bill Burr
asked me how my relationship was once at
the ice house and I said well it's weird
because she asked me she called me a
scared [__] and he said nah you got to
get rid of her and that's when I
realized had to get rid of her so thanks
Bill so to deeper but I'm not a scared
[__] and I'm not going to let the OCD
demon as they say control my life so I
say you know technically it's not really
from Taco Bell you can get that anywhere
so I [__] I mean I know they do
specialize with the Baja Blast but it's
probably just like Sprite and [__]
you know Spot Shot and some ice so let
me just [__] you know it's like neon
I'm like I'm not going to look I'm not
going to like it I promise and then she
goes well with that attitude and I'm
like no no I don't want you to do that
because I wasn't done talking Whoopsie
Daisy we interrupted
me if I drink it I'm going to let my
walls down I'm going to sip it
twice and I'm going to absolutely give
you the God's honest truth from within
my
heart and she
says okay and I say I'll try the Baja
Blast cuz it's not technical techically
Taco Bell it's kind of just in their
drink
system so she says here and I grab it I
smell it because I want to know if I
actually sincerely don't want to drink
it because if it smells putrid I'm just
not going to put it in my mouth I smell
it it passes the smell test it smells
bad but I'm like okay I'll do it I take
one
sip I let it sit I don't judge it yet
because I'm not a piece of [__]
dude I take another sip just like I said
I was and my buddy's girlfriend says o
that means he likes it and then of
course I feel my blood inside my heart
because I said I'm going to take two
sips to make a good judgment and now
she's trying to push an
agenda
okay so I take that second Sip and I
said no I didn't take
that this kind of [__] that this is the
kind of [__] life that I have this is
the [__] that like we talk
about and I say no I said I was going to
take a second sip because I wanted to
judge it fairly because I told you I
wanted to judge it fairly and I'm a man
of my word
okay and she said
okay I let it sit in my head I didn't
just taste it with my tongue I tasted it
with my head you know you ever taste
something with your whole head that's
when you really know how banged it is
right you don't just let it [__]
ruminate on your pallet you let it
envelop your whole [__] head I let it
envelop my whole [__]
head and it turns out that the Baja
Blast from Taco Bell is [__]
awful and that's the God's honest truth
so I hand it back and I say it's awful
and I mean that with my heart and they
go oh come on and I say it tastes like
Windex and I said to the guy does it
taste like Windex or am I bullshitting
and he goes like this I mean you know
and I go
ah so it does taste like Windex a little
bit it's not good
dude I hate to say I told you so but I
gave a God's honest review of the Baja
Blast and it's
bad so [__] yeah now I kind of I danced
with Taco Bell right I didn't take Taco
Bell but I danced with it in the soft
Moonlight a little bit
do you know what I'm talking about I
didn't eat Taco Bell but I let it dance
on my taste buds into the pallet and
also ruminate in my head a little bit
without eating any meat cheese or sour
cream so I danced with it I danced with
Taco Bell in the pale Moonlight but I
didn't [__] with Taco Bell so that just
made it so I'm never eating Taco Taco
Bell again so dude he won yes he got out
of that one